[Musique]
en voyant la nouvelle gouvernance de
france télévisions je suis très ému
parce que sans eux je serais pas là ce
soir avec toi ils ont été d'une rare
élégance et j'aime le répéter et je
voudrais dire bravo et merci à ce qu'il
faudrait pour remercier la culotte et
stéphane sitbon domaine qui est un
garçon exceptionnel voilà prendre je le
dis vous savez qu'en plus je dis tout
vous avez vu je suis pas le genre à
voile à passer la pommade stéphane simon
gauthier numéro 2 de france télévisions
et qui j'étais à la fois et qui me
disait quel bonheur de retrouver michel
à l'antenne il était tellement heureux
de te retrouves à l'antenne et il m'a
dit il validera il m'a dit tu rends
compte michel il est parti il est revenu
et il fait toujours les mêmes cartons
les gens l'attendent et les hommes voilà
les gens étaient devant leur poste ils
attendaient michel mais tu connais ce
métier battant très très bien c'est que
quand tu es vraiment aux portes du
gouffre et que dans sa chambre d'hôpital
il ya là président de france télévisions
delphine ernotte et puis s'était
facilement gomez qui viennent me voir
jordi voilà j'ai caché tout ça parce que
le hasard c'est le loup ou chien comme
histoire qui tendent vers la castagne n
était plus dans l'émission et des
bouffées pas son portable
c'est à dire que le hasard a voulu que
je sois hospitalisés à 50 mètres du
bureau de mes patrons
5 voir sous un autre nom et pendant un
mois il ne savait pas que j'étais sous
perfusion dans la chambre 36-18 à se
remettre de leur bureau
alors je devrai dit faut venir me voir
parce que je vais peut-être vous dire
aurevoir définitivement parce que j'ai
les petits soucis
ils n'ont pas compris money mais michel
qu'est ce qui se passe je venais venez
me voir ils sont venus le lendemain ils
m'ont découvert la perfusion depuis un
mois et je leur dis voilà c'est vous
dire au revoir parce que ce qui m'attend
sur la table d'opération demain est
tellement compliqué que même si je
reviens je serai diminué donc je vais
dire au revoir à ce métier et à partir
du 30 août dernier tu vas passer son
jour dans le plus grand secret à
l'hôpital pompidou
le livre commence à la veille de son
opération à coeur ouvert à cause d'une
suite de pépin cardiaque comme tu dis
est très vite dans l'île tu évoques
l'injustice d'avoir de tels soucis de
santé
et c'est ce que j'ai pensé tout de suite
je te jure elle sans avoir fumé but en
ayant fait du sport et tu te jure c'est
la première chose à laquelle j'ai pensé
oui mais c'est ce qui m'a sauvé c'est
changerait m'a dit si vous aviez
vingt kilos de plus avait picolé fumée
et si vous aviez une vie un peu
compliqué je vous aurais pas opéré par
max royer resté sur la table d'opération
c'est ce qui m'a même temps sauver parce
que moi je suis comme je suis un peu la
même vie je me suis dit bon ben voilà
mitchell c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai
ouais ouais tu te couches très tôt la
wii non mais c'est vrai michel une union
l'une des repas sains
winder pas ça elle peut doit être bu je
dormais quand même nombreux mois il
m'arrive la pl 3 heures du matin il est
saoul et là il regarde les audiences
[Rires]
tu sais tu tg vous l'été d'un slip sur
tout et tu l'as vu jeudi dédiée aux
chirurgiens ou ccao grand cardiologue
qui en france qui sont parmi les
meilleurs du monde le professeur
carpentier c'est lui le vanter le coeur
artificiel
on peut au 4 entier sait ces quarts car
matt le quart matt c'est carpentier et
matra jean luc lagardère
ainsi jean-luc lagardère et matra qui
ont financé le premier coeur artificiel
il faut le dire mais j'ai voulu écrire
ce livre pour rendre hommage aux
infirmes et en personnel soignant à
l'hôpital public parce que je
connaissais un peu cet univers puisque
je viens du milieu médical par mon père
et mon frère mon jeune frère
mais lorsqu'on est lorsqu'on va à
l'hôpital voir un copain malade je suis
accompagné beaucoup d'amis célèbres
malheureusement dans la dernière ligne
droite mais quand on est soi-même le
patient au goutte à goutte c'est puis la
même chose et donc j'ai vu ce que
c'était que le suspect d'enfermement ce
de silence la morphine des antidouleurs
délaissé par yale il portait c'est vrai
que j'ai voulu que leur slip pour rendre
hommage au personnel soignant aux
infirmières qu'on applaudisse et
beaucoup sur les balkans il ya un an et
qu'on a oublié depuis non les a pas
oubliés un il faut pas les oublier
surtout alors tu penses que tu as trop
forcé sur ton coeur à cause du vélo
non je crois que c'est j'ai trop forcé
par le stress vraiment ah ouais ouais
pas stressé de quoi bein 57 ans de télé
ça fait beaucoup 53 mais ramé sur les
plus durs
c'est beaucoup de stress c'est vrai
vraiment et je me suis mis une grosse
grosse pression au cours des dernières
années
en voulant réaliser un challenge dont je
rêvais toi aussi d'aller sur scène
maintenant je suis allé sur scène
alalala journée de la retraite depuis
longtemps et ça ça m'a beaucoup stressé
mais mes jeux
en son genre médecins m'ont dit que
c'était ça dimon dit bon j'avais eu des
alertes ou pas avant j'étais un petit
peu essoufflé j'aimerais que trois
petits l'essoufflement sur le vélo j'ai
fait le ventoux trois fois trop tôt j'ai
fait le téléthon en vélo j'avais déjà 50
balais 520km gelé dans les sous-marins
nucléaires je suis allé sur la calypso
avec cousteau je suis avec besson sous
la banquise
j'ai fait beaucoup beaucoup de conneries
dans madame est sauté en parachute
j'ai fait beaucoup de choses je les sons
charles de gaulle plusieurs fois parce
que j'aime ça et que seul le sport c'est
ma passion c'était ma vie j'ai faisait 1
coupe du monde mais j'ai sans doute
était beaucoup trop impliqué pendant ce
métier trop stressé car c'est
contrairement à ce qu'on pense c'est un
métier de stress un métier d'angoissé en
plus j'ai fait une parano dans laquelle
j'ai pas revenir pendant trois ou quatre
ans j'ai vraiment cru que j'étais trop
vieux qu'il fallait que je pars donc ça
va beaucoup travailler parce que on en a
souvent parlé tous les deux je me disais
comment sortir par le haut comment
comment sortir avant conteuse ap
comment partir dignement et pas faire le
fameux combat trop ça c'est le sport tu
feras jamais le combat de trop en fait
je le lis mature façon le cardio m'ont
dit avec le coeur quand vous avez vous
êtes là pour cent ans
bon bah manif donc les jeunes attendront
encore me rassure c'est 8 après sur
canal ça sent le patron c'est pas
[Rires]